der Super Bowl ist wahrscheinlich das
wichtigste Ereignis in der
US-amerikanischen Sportwelt zumindest
was die Finanzen angeht allein das 203er
Finale der American Football profila zog
65 000 Zuschauer in state Farm Stadium
in Arizona 65 000 Menschen sind verdammt
viel auf einem Haufen aber selbst diese
Menge verblasst im Vergleich zu der
erschreckenden Zahl von 107 000 Menschen
die im Jahr 2022 in den USA an einer
Überdosis Drogen starben Menschen um das
Michigan Stadium das größte Sportstadion
in ganz Nordamerika zu füllen und von
diesen 107000 Menschen haben 70 000 ihr
Leben durch Fentanyl verloren das
derzeit die größte gesundheitliche
Bedrohung für das ganze Land darstellt
eine soziale und gesundheitliche Krise
die völlig außer Kontrolle geraten ist 3
mai 2023 die Zahl der fentanylbedingten
Todesfälle in den USA hat sich innerhalb
von 5 Jahren mehr als verdreifacht nach
Angaben des us-zentrums für solchen und
Prävention CDC stieg die Zahl der
Todesfälle durch eine Überdosis Fentanyl
von 5,7 pro 100.000 Menschen im Jahr
2016 auf 21,6 pro 100000 im Jahr 2021
70.000 Todesfälle durch Fentanyl
reichten aus um das Thema in die Rede
zur Lage der Nation von Präsident Biden
einzuschleusen es war einer der wenigen
Momente in denen sowohl Demokraten als
auch Republikaner den Präsidenten
applaudierten
[Applaus]
und das hat visualpolitik dazu
veranlasst ein paar Fragen zu stellen
wie konnte der fentanylkonsum so außer
Kontrolle geraten wer produziert es und
auf welche Weise wie verändert es die
Muster des Drogenkonsums wie weit könnte
eine Krise reichen die von vielen
bereits als stille Pandemien bezeichnet
wird am Ende dieses Videos werdet ihr
die Antworten auf all diese Fragen
wissen und nebenbei dies ist vielleicht
eines der Videos auf das wir lieber
verzichtet hätten aber gleichzeitig auch
eines der wichtigsten denn wenn es etwas
gibt das klargestellt werden muss dann
ist es die Tatsache dass wir es weder
mit einer trivialen Angelegenheit noch
mit etwas zu tun haben dass man
kontrollieren kann und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass euch nach einigen
Daten die wir euch in diesem Video
zeigen werden die Spucke weg bleiben
wird das heutige Video hat übrigens
unser treuer Sponsor surfchark möglich
gemacht und deswegen müssen wir das
heißt meine weihnachtskatze Angie und
ich euch unbedingt noch sein besonderes
Weihnachtsangebot vorstellen denn
solltet ihr noch kein VPN haben ist dies
nur die einmalige Gelegenheit es so
günstig wie noch nie zu bekommen wusst
ihr z.B dass viele Firmen wie Social
Airlines ganz unterschiedliche Preise
anbieten können je nachdem von welchem
Land aus man bestellt bzw sein Ticket
Bucht aber zum Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe als
VPNs überlisten und dann richtig Geld
sparen surfshark VPN ist dabei ein
wirklich empfehlensswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mitlckt ein Virtual
Private networkz VPN ist aber nicht nur
zum geldparen geeignet es kann einen
auch vor so mancher größeren
gefahrschützen die im Netz lauert
natürlich muss man nach wie vor Umsicht
walten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierf ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum ein
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im NZ
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im NZ erhöhen z.B
mit dem integrierten cleanwb das alle
unerwünschen Cookies und Pop-ups blockt
weiter Vorteil VPN ist dass ihr so tun
könnt als wäret ihr an einem anderen Ort
nur könnt ihr z.B Websites und
Internetdienste zugreifen dem Land den
ihr gerade seid nicht verfügbar wäen ob
daheim oder auf Reisen damit schlagt i
Zensur geoblocking ein Schnippchen
Netflix und andere Streamingdienste die
ihre Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten von
Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surf kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles mit nur einem sur
Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VP registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren smartvone so
und wenn ihr den Rabattkode politikde
angeht bekommt ihr von sursar im Rahmen
des weihnachtsspecials auch noch
zusätzliche 6 Monate gratis dazu den
Link zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video na I was
sagst du
dazu also nichts wie los besorgt euch
surfshark und surft ab jetzt sicher und
ohne diskriminiert zu werden im Internet
also lasst uns sofort
[Applaus]
[Musik]
loslegen wir wollen hier nicht allzu
sehr ins Detail gen weil es sich
offensichtlich nicht um unser Fachgebiet
handelt aber wir können sagen dass es
bisher drei Hauptklassen von Opiaten
gibt opiumalkaloide wie Morphin und
Kodein halbsynthetische opiode wie
Heroin und oxyodon und vollsynthetische
Opioide wie petidin und metadon und
Fentanyl fällt als vollständig
synthetisches Opioid in die letzte
Kategorie aber wie fast alle
Betäubungsmittel hat es einen viel
edleren und nützlicheren Ursprung es
wurde nämlich entwickelt um als
Schmerzmittel für Menschen mit Krebs
oder andere schwer ihren schmerzhaften
Krankheiten eingesetzt zu werden und das
wird es derzeit auch es handelt sich um
eine Substanz die die Wirkung von
Morphin im menschlichen Körper nachaht
aber mit einem wichtigen Unterschied sie
ist 50 bis 100 mal stärker infolg dessen
gibt es bis zu 50 abgeleitete
Medikamente die aus Fentanyl hergestellt
werden können was seine Verbreitung
enorm vergrößert und komplex macht und
vielleicht ist das der Grund warum n
Milgram die Direktorin der obersten US
antidrogenbehörde dea im November 2022
Fentanyl als das tödlichste Rauschgift
aller Zeiten in den USA bezeichnete
Fentanyl ist die tödlichste
pharmakologische Bedrohung der unserer
Nation je ausgesetzt war und nimmt euch
in acht denn bis jetzt haben schon mehr
als 287 000 Menschen ihr Leben durch
diese Substanz verloren und täcklich
werden es immer mehr aber um die
wirklichen Auswirkungen von Fentanyl zu
verstehen und zu begreifen wovon wir
hier überhaupt sprechen sollten wir ganz
am Anfang
beginnen
ein makaberer
Zufall Fentanyl wurde erstmals 1960 von
Paul Jansen einem belgischen Chemiker
der für jansenfarmazeutiker arbeitete
synthetisiert in der Folgezeit wurde es
als Schmerzmittel in vielen
verschiedenen Formen vermarktet als
Pflaster Lutscher Lutschtablette Spray
und als intravenöse Dosis behalte dies
im Hinterkopf denn es handelt sich um
ein durchaus wichtiges Detail und
bereits in den 1990er Jahren entdeckte
die da in kensis einen der ersten Fälle
von illegal hergestellten Fentanyl in
den USA aber von da an war die
Abwärtsspirale nicht mehr
[Musik]
aufzuhalten zwischen den Jahren 2000 und
2005 haben die US-Behörden mehrere
geheime fentanyllabore im ganzen Land
aufgespürt und ausgehoben was deutlich
zu machen schien dass das Ausmaß der
fentanylproduktion exponentiell zunahm
tatsächlich verdoppelte sich im selben
Zeitraum auch die Zahl der Todesopfer zu
dieser Zeit wurde fentanül auf der
Straße mit Heroin
gemischt und deshalb drät sich die Frage
auf wer stellt es überhaupt her und wo
wird es hergestellt zumindest nach
Angaben der US-Regierung sind Mexikos
größte drogenhändlergruppen die neue
Generation von Sinaloa und kalisco die
Hauptschuldigen wie Washington
anprangert beziehen diese Gruppen die
für die Herstellung synthetischer
Opioide benötigten vorläuferchemikalien
aus China stellen die Substanz dann in
geheimen Laboren in Mexiko her und
schmuggeln sie schließlich in die USA
und wie wir euch in diesem Video zeigen
werden handelt es sich dabei
wahrscheinlich um das einfachste und
beste Business das sie machen können die
USA beschuldigen aber auch China die
Augen zu verschließen einigen Analysten
zufolge könnte Peking mit dieser
Situation sogar zufrieden sein die
pseudokommunisten könnten die
drogenepidemie zu einem ihrer
verhandlungsmittel machen ihr seht also
dass das Ganze durchaus auch eine
geopolitische Dimension hat aber haltet
euch fest denn das ist noch nicht einmal
das ganze Ausmaß des
Problems
also ob das alles noch nicht genug wäre
begannen Pharmaunternehmen zu Beginn
dieses Jahrhunderts die Verschreibung
von Fentanyl und anderen Opioiden mit
massiven Marketingkampagne zu fördern
diese Kampagnen zielten vor allem auf
einkommensschwache Schichten ab und die
Wahrheit ist dass es in dieser
Angelegenheit im Allgemeinen nicht viel
Kontrolle gab obwohl diese Substanz
furchtbar süchtig machte und noch immer
acht 21 Oktober 2020 perdue Pharma
bekennt sich zu Strafanzeigen wegen
opioidverkäufen das Justizministerium
kündigte einen Vergleich in Höhe von 8
Milliarden Dollar mit dem Unternehmen an
mit anderen Worten im ersten Jahrzehnt
dieses Jahrhunderts wurde ein hochgradig
explosiver Cocktail gemischt zum einen
der Missbrauch von ärztlich
verschriebenen therapeutischen Opioiden
zum anderen der zunehmende Konsum von
Fentanyl das auf dem illegalen Markt mit
anderen Betäubungsmitteln gemischt wird
und auf diese Weise schoss der Konsum
einfach in die Höhe es begann ein
Albtraum der den Krieg gegen Drogen im
Grunde zu einem Witz gemacht hat ganz
genau so etwas haben wir noch nie erlebt
aber warum ist Fentanyl eigentlich
plötzlich so beliebt warum wird es
konsumiert wenn man weiß dass es so
viele Risiken wirgt und wer ist davon am
meisten betroffen genau das werden wir
jetzt unter die Lupe
nehmen ein tödliches
[Musik]
Schnäppchen meine Lieben Zuschauer die
drogenkrise ist so groß dass ich seit 5
Jahren der Haupt Faktor ist der die
durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung in den
USA sinken lässt ganz genau ihr habt
richtig gehört die folgende Nachricht
ist aus dem Jahr
2017 22 dezember 2017 die
durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung in den
USA sinkt in der opioidkrise und seitdem
ist es natürlich noch schlimmer geworden
viel schlimmer zu Fentanyl kam noch die
coronapandemie und die lockdowns hinzu
und das Ergebnis nun werf mal einen
Blick auf diese Grafik wie ihr dem
Diagramm leicht entnehmen könnt ist die
lebenserwart in allen Ländern während
der coronazeit gesunken aber die USA
sind das einzige Land in den die
Lebenserwartung während der Pandemie
gesunken ist und
2021 erneut und genau das ist die Folge
von Fentanyl offiziellen Daten zufolge
steigt die Zahl der Opfer von
Überdosierungen in den USA seit mehr als
20 Jahren an aber Fentanyl hat einen
echten Wendepunkt dargestellt die
Tatsache dass fast 70% aller Todesfälle
auf Fentanyl zurückzuführen ist macht
deutlich wie dieses Rauschgift alles
verändert hat es ist zu einem echten
Tsunami geworden vor allem für jüngere
Menschen wollt ihr eine erschütternde
Tatsache hören Fentanyl ist für 80%
aller Todesfälle in der Altersgruppe
zwischen 15 und 24 Jahren verantwortlich
diese Substanz ist die häufigste
Todesursache bei jungen Amerikanern und
auch für die die nicht mehr so jung sind
ist eine Überdosis bereit die häufigste
Todesursache für Amerikaner unter 45
Jahren schaut es euch
an und wohlgemerkt all das ohne dass der
Konsum dieser Droge so weit verbreitet
ist wie wir vielleicht erwarten würden
denn Fentanyl ist glücklicherweise immer
noch kein gängiges Rauschgift aber das
Problem ist dass seine Opferzahlen nicht
mit den anderer Substanzen vergleichbar
sind laut dem US-amerikanischen national
forensic laboratory Information System
wird es z.B in Berichten über
rauschgifttests nur in etwas mehr als
13% der positiven Fälle nachgewiesen und
das obwohl es für 70% der Todesfälle
verantwortlich ist könnt ihr euch also
vorstellen was passieren würde wenn sein
Gebrauch noch weiter ansteigen würde
dann würde es sich um eine Katastrophe
wahrlich epischen Ausmaßes Handeln
Fentanyl hat bereits jetzt fünfm so
viele Amerikaner getötet wie der gesamte
Vietnamkrieg und es wird immer schlimmer
aber an dieser Stelle fragt ihr euch
sicher wie sich diese Substanz in den
USA überhaupt so stark ausbreiten und
einen solchen Tsunami auslösen konnte
nun das liegt vor allem an drei
Faktoren erstens weil diese Substanz so
stark ist dass kriminelle Gruppen mit
einem Kilogramm davon etwa eine Million
gefälschte Pillen herstellen können und
diese können Sie dann als eine Art von
halluzinogener Substanz mit einem etwas
besseren Ruf verkaufen die Zunahme des
fentanylkonsums spiegelt die Potenz
dieser Substanz und ihre niedrigen
Produktionskosten wieder Händler haben
starke anreisee Fentanyl mit Heroin und
anderen straßendrogen zu mischen die
Herstellung von Fentanyl in präzisen
Dosen erfordert außerdem spezielle
Ausrüstung und Fachkenntnisse und das
ist kein Überraschung es bringt uns
nämlich direkt zum zweiten Faktor
während für eine tödliche Dosis anderer
Substanzen mehr als 20 mg des Produkts
erfordererlich sein können liegt die
tödliche Dosis bei Fentanyl bei nur 2
oder 3 mg und das sind ein oder zwei
gefälschte Pillen aber zu allem
Überfluss und das ist der dritte Grund
der diese enorme Krise ausgelöst hat ist
Fentanyl auch noch unglaublich billig
shht euch z.B die Preise an die eine
gemeinsame Studie mehrer Universitäten
im Jahr 2020 ergründet hat wie ihr an
der starken Verteilung an
Kleinverbraucher sehen könnt handelt es
sich wenn wir berücksichtigen dass für
die enorme Potenz des Produkts weniger
Menge benötigt wird relativ gesehen um
eine sehr billige Substanz und das macht
sie so furchtbar die Kosten für eine
tödliche Menge Fentanyl liegen bei
weniger als z Cent im Vergleich zu mehr
als 7 $ für andere gefährliche
Substanzen und der Punkt ist dass diese
drei Gründe erklären warum Fentanyl so
verherrende Auswirkungen hat und warum
vor allem auch junge Menschen davon
betroffen sind um es noch einmal
zusammenzufassen erst erens ist Fentanyl
allgegenwertig zweitens macht es sehr
starksüchtig und die tödliche Dosis ist
erschreckend niedrig und drittens ist es
sehr
billig und all das macht sie besonders
gefährlich so sehr dass viele Experten
bereits von einer stillen Pandemie
sprechen einer Pandemie die sich sogar
über die USA hinaus ausbereiten und
exponentiell eskalieren könnte genau aus
diesem Grund hat die da Fentanyl zu
ihrem Ziel Nummer 1 gemacht aber es ist
noch noch nicht einmal klar wie man des
Problems habbhaft werden könnte
kriminelle Kartelle in Mexiko und China
Handeln weiterhin ungestraft wir
brauchen größere durchsetzungsbefugnisse
und mehr Rechenschaftspflicht seitens
unserer eigenen Regierung aber weißt du
was dieser Prozess der internationalen
Expansion des fentanyls hat vielleicht
sogar schon
[Musik]
begonnen eine stille Pandemie die kurz
vor dem Ausbruch
steht lasst uns mal über einen Aspekt
nachdenken wenn es sich um ein
Rauschgift handelt das so billig und
leicht zu transportieren ist warum
sollte es dann nur auf die USA
beschränkt bleiben in der Tat könnten
wir es bald mit einem wahren Makro
Tsunami zu tun haben der auch den Rest
der Welt erfasst besonders die ärmsten
Regionen und wisst ihr was im Moment
sieht es so aus als könnte diese Welle
bereits Lateinamerika erreicht haben in
Mexiko z.B hat Präsident amlo seit
Anfang des Jahres gesagt dass diese
Substanz nicht in Mexiko hergestellt
wird sondern dass dieses Land nur als
transitlad diene jetzt aber musste er
zugeben dass es auch in Mexiko fentanyll
laabore gibt Labore die natürlich nicht
nur für die USA produzieren aber Mexiko
ist bei weiten nicht das einzige Land
das Alarm geschlagen hat 2 juni 2023 so
wird Fentanyl in Bogota verkauft es wird
mit Medikamenten für Pferde kombiniert
wohl gemerkt wir reden hier bisher nur
über
Lateinamerika wir müssen Fentanyl aus
Europa heraushalten fordert der
Justizminister er bezieht sich dabei
natürlich auf Fentanyl das auf dem
Schwarzmarkt gehandelt wird in Europa
ist die Lage durchaus noch unter
Kontrolle die Zahl der Opfer einer
tödlichen Überdosis liegt in der
Europäischen Union bei gerade mal 6% der
in den USA registrierten Fälle aber es
gibt bereits einige beunruhigende
Nachrichten sowohl Schweden als auch
Finnland meldeten in den letzten Jahren
einen lokalen Anstieg des
fentanylkonsums und der
fentanylbedingten Todesfälle in
Deutschland wurde ein besorgniserregend
hoher fentanylkonsum unter
opioidkonsumenten festgestellt der sich
in einer hohen Zahl von
fentanylbedingten Todesfällen
widerspiegelt könnte die Situation also
auch in Europa außer Kontrolle geraten
so wie es in den USA passiert
ist nun die Wahrheit ist dass es sich um
ein Thema handelt das allmählich große
Besorgnis erregt schließlich ist diese
Substanz extrem schwer fassbar für die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden ist es
schwierig Fentanyl aufzuspüren da es
aufgrund seiner hohenpotenz nur in
kleinen Mengen handelt wird und meist
mit anderen Drogen vermischt oder unter
dem Namen einer anderen Droge verkauft
wird mit anderen Worten es ist leicht zu
transportieren sehr schwer zu entdecken
und die Verbraucher müssen sich nicht
einmal bewusst sein dass sie es
konsumieren wisst ihr noch was wir
vorhin über die enorme Vielfalt an
Formen gesagt haben die Fentanyl
annehmen kann nun genau darum geht es
man kann es so gut wie keine andere
Substanz tarnen auf diese Weise können
kriminelle Gruppen mit kleinen Mengen
die sich leicht in den Taschen oder
Rucksäcken der Menschen verstecken
lassen riesige Gewinne erzielen es
handelt sich um einen wahren Albtraum
und die Frage lautet wie wird dieser
makabere Tsunami auf den Rest der Welt
übergreifen wie kann er aufgehalten
werden werden die USA bald in der Lage
sein diese epochale Gesundheitskrise zu
überwinden hinterlasst uns eure Gedanken
in den Kommentaren und seid euch der
enormen Gefahr bewusst die von diesem
Thema ausgeht ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video trotzdem gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gebt ihn bitte ein Like und
teilt es auch mit euren Freunden
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit un Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald